hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip
on getting depth of field inside of
after effects
with cinema 4d files
so here we are inside of cinema 4d and
i've got a very simple
scene set up i've got a floor and i've
got two boxes and i've got some lights
set up as well so that it looks like
this
pretty straightforward and simple oh and
one thing i want to mention before we
jump into this is that this
is a floor object okay so that means
that this floor object extends
all the way back here all the way back
here it fills the entire frame
so if this was just a plane with a wood
texture applied
the plane would actually cut off here
and when you're looking through the
camera that can create
some issues with creating depth of field
inside of after effects
if there's an alpha channel or something
like that
it can kind of play havoc so i just
wanted to point out that this
is a floor object so the scene
extends all the way off into the
darkness
and we'll add a camera here this first
thing we're going to do we're going to
add a camera
and if i look through that camera by
clicking the white button here
and i rotate around to
get oh a somewhat interesting
angle like
you know maybe something pretty tight
like this
again if this was just a plane this
would be alpha channel back here
but the floor extends all the way back
here all the way back here
and back here so it can create issues
if you don't have a set that extends all
the way back
so just want to point that out so we've
got our camera set up here so the first
thing we're going to do is we're
actually now going to jump
right back out of that camera so we're
looking at it
and we're going to go into our focus
distance okay
so we're going to bring that focus
distance i'm just clicking and holding
down and dragging
and i'm bringing that focus distance
probably
maybe down in here okay somewhere right
in here doesn't matter this is all
experimentation
and that is our focal plane here i can
also click and drag here
and it adjusts the focal distance as
well
next i'm going to do is click on details
okay and under details
rear blur we're going to enable that and
you can see now there's a second plane
here i can click and drag
here i can bring that rear blur up here
i can also click and drag here
different ways you can adjust it so
we'll click on the white dot again to
look back through the camera
we're going to hit render and
you're going to see there's no depth of
field happening because now we need to
jump into after effects
and add that depth of field
okay so here we are inside of after
effects and i
imported my cinema 4d file into after
effects
you can see it right here it's the
actual cinema 4d file it is not the
render this is the file
i'm going to change it to standard final
so that
we can get a full res render here of
what's going on
and you can see i've got three effects
applied here and these are the effects
i'm going to use to
show you how to accomplish this so first
i'm going to do is we're going to select
the layer down here on our timeline
command d to duplicate or go up to edit
duplicate here so we have a layer above
and this top layer does not need
these extra effects i applied to it so
there it is we're going to solo this
layer
we're going to go up to cinema 4d
multipass we're going to select that
we're going to that enables us to click
click on this button we're going to
click that button and it's going to say
what do you want for your depth for your
multi-pass we want depth which is the
top one here there's all these different
options here it's really cool we're
gonna select depth
okay and what's gonna happen here is our
image here
is going to turn into a depth
map image which here we can see there it
is
you can see this black line down here if
i jump into
cinema 4d that if i jump out of the
camera here
that is where this focal plane is so
this focal plane is
right in front of that box on the ground
here
if you jump back into after effects you
can see that's where this line is
okay and our back blur is what's
creating
this depth here the white there's
another box back here is completely
white
okay so we're going to turn we're going
to unsolo this
we're going to turn off this layer so
that is our depth map
layer back on our original
cinema 4d file with our third with our
plugins this first plugin
is camera lens blur which is built into
after effects it's here under effect
blur and sharpen
camera lens blur there it is everyone
has this effect
effect blur and sharpen camera lens blur
okay
it is built into after effects we apply
it and you can immediately see that
everything here
is already blurry doesn't look quite
right because everything is blurry right
because it defaults to a blur radius of
five
so the first thing we do is i'm going to
click repeat edge pixels to get rid of
these
kind of weird edge pixels and i'm going
to select
blur map and i'm going to select layer
number one which is the
layer that we turned into our depth mat
okay and there you go you can see the
background is out of focus the
foreground is in focus
so i can turn the radius now up to 10.
it's getting even more blurry in the
background maybe
15. the front is staying in focus
and there you go you have depth of field
i can adjust things like i can invert
the blur map
click that now everything in the
background that's white
is in focus everything that's gray and
black
in the foreground is out of focus if we
turn that back off we can also adjust
the focus distance like we can
here and it's going to change our focus
distance
in our image here it's a really simple
way to
create depth of field inside of after
effects i prefer to work with
one of these two plugins here this first
one is from
fresh lift depth of field okay so this
is under effect
fresh lift depth of field i've talked
about their curve plugins and other
lessons
depth of field is very powerful it's
very quick
all i have to do is change the depth
layer here to our layer number one
which is our depth map and by default
it's set to zero so i can just
start increasing this and you're going
to see
what happens once it actually activates
there it goes we've got some really nice
blur i'm going to increase this what's
fun about this plugin is i can actually
click here select depth
and i can go into my image here and
start selecting points where i want my
depth to be focused like maybe the back
edge of this square or
maybe down here or maybe here
and you can see it's creating depth
wherever i place that so really really
nice
easy to use third-party plug-in it's
also got more options
inside of these dropdowns here
and the last one i like to use is from
sapphire it's called z-blur
again it applies blur to everything i'm
gonna go to z buffer
changes from none to the first layer
there we go
i can increase the focal depth something
like that
um i can also reverse it say
black is near and it's going to do the
reverse effect
there so really powerful stuff really
easy to
play around with this that is how you
create
interesting depth of field inside of
after effects
with cinema 4d files